>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Okay, take one, roll film.
Action.
>> Opus, dear boy, we're
ready to shoot the scene.
>> Call my stunt double.
>> Yes, I know it's tricky,
Darling, but you can nail it.
>> I don't do whales.
>> Whales?
Good God, there's no whales.
This is the big love scene, darling.
>> Fibber!
>> Don't speak rubbish, Sweetheart,
we're Hollywood people, not liars!
>> It says right here on
the schedule, Scene One,
the rabid killer whale
rockets up from the hole
and grabs our little
hero, and snapping jaws,
and rips the stuffing out of him.
>> No, no, truly, my boy.
We changed the schedule.
It's the kissing scene on a
tropical beach with Nicole Kidman.
>> Well, that's a different
kettle of beans.
I have some ideas, if I may.
You see you take your [inaudible]
and then you [inaudible] like this,
and then you purse out
your lips, you see.
The females just love it.
Oh, gosh. I hope she likes
herring stomach omelets.
Listen, no nude shots, okay?
My pants stay on!
Okay, no pants.
Because I want Ms. Kidman protected.
She is not the kind of girl
that shows her niblets!
Oh, I hope she's gentle.
Ms. Kidman?
>> Cut! Very, very, very good.
Print.
>> Mama, what a woman.
[ Music ]
>> I love humans.
Like penguins.
They're noble, perfect,
attractive animals in every way.
Except for their bottom plumage.
Wait! What temptation is this?
I am irresistibly compelled to
complete their unfinished voyage!
I must not, for the sake
of all that is holy.
I must not.
No! Yes! [inaudible] don't do it!
Take him down.
No! You must!
I won't!
No. I'm just not that mean.
[ Music ]
You know, sometimes the
rear ends justify the means.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Was that amazing?
You know, I wasn't planning
on this, but a big hand
for Sophie Breathed,
who edited that, please.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Although we have a lot of
young people here tonight
for Graphic Novel Night, and
again, if you weren't here before,
Michael Cavna, a Comic
Riffs blogger, columnist,
cartoonist with the Washington
Post, and the comic strip Warped.
I know we have a lot
of young people here,
but anyone here remember
the 80s at all?
Anyone? Yes?
I see hands.
I think I see a few penguin
fins, because, you know,
we'd come out of the hostage crisis,
we'd come out of waiting in --
anyone remember odds
and end days for gas?
And then Reagan comes to office
and, well, it was a different time.
And suddenly, we needed innocence,
but we needed skewed innocence.
We needed a sweetheart, maybe
from a polar ice cap before
it started melting too much.
And what we got was, you know,
I'll say this as a cartoonist.
You're lucky if you get one
creation in your whole career
that really touches people, that
moves people, if you get one Snoopy.
And in the 80s, we got Opus.
And, you know, how about
a big hand for Opus.
What we got with him, we got Bill
the Cat, and we got Steve Dallas.
Nice. We got Bill the Cat, which was
sort of Garfield without Garfield
with Garfield in a twisted way.
We got Steve Dallas, who seemed
to [inaudible] Michael Douglas,
you know, skewering greed-is-good
80s, and we just got --
we got the metal party
when we needed him.
It just was an amazing
cast of characters.
And, you know, they don't go away.
Look at that.
So what we have now is they're back.
We've been through Pete and
Pickles, and we've got, you know,
all these beautiful new books,
but one man, one Pulitzer winner,
one screenwriter, one director, one
illustrator, all from [inaudible].
Last year, boom, popped up
last summer on Facebook.
Did anyone hear Poplook
Facebook last summer
and see Bloom County returns?
[ Applause ]
Now, thankfully, we get him.
It's like a blast from the
past that we really needed,
and it's from the genius
mind of Berkeley Breathed.
Please welcome up here,
Berkeley Breathed.
[ Applause ]
>> Very nice, Michael, thank you.
Am I on? Am I on?
Right. Wow, this is so
much fun, being back.
And it's kind of what I
wanted to quickly go through.
Everyone wants to know why,
and it is a good question.
I even had to ask myself and think
about it before I had a good
ready-made answer for it.
Which is why it was -- this is a
great opportunity to go over it
with you, my extended family.
We're ready to go?
Well, let me put the next slide up.
So, again, why?
And I wanted a glib,
easy one-sentence answer,
and it actually didn't exist.
So I went back and thought about it
and I realized there were three
things like so often in life
that all come together,
you didn't expect it,
and it forms something new, and it
forms a new idea, and it puts you
in a place like me, that was
never -- I was never going to --
I didn't think I was
going to go to again.
Because when I stopped Bloom County,
I really had never thought
ever, ever, ever going back.
So why all of a sudden
was it a good idea?
And there were -- it's sort
of a triangle of causation,
and the first side of
it, believe it or not,
was one of my children's books
called "Mars Needs Moms,"
which is -- it is my
favorite of my books,
short of the new Bill the Cat book.
But it was drawn and written out
of a particular moment in my life
when I watched my son, who was
-- Milo, who's there, who's --
the book is -- stars Milo, say
something very, very, very,
very bad, and unfortunate
to his mother.
And I wrote the book that night
and spent the next six weeks
illustrating it in a frenzy.
And it basically tells
the story of a bunch
of Martians that come down to Mars.
They don't have moms on Mars.
They need one.
They think that they know what
moms are good for, and they come
and they steal Milo's mom,
who he has just said
some horrible things to,
and clearly doesn't appreciate
his mom like he should.
And this is a look at the book here.
So, as you might expect, it's
fun and silly and whimsical.
And he ends up very badly needing
a space helmet that he broke,
and his mom that's on Mars comes
over and takes off her helmet
and gives it to him
while she slowly dies.
That's the moment that I was
hoping my child might understand
about their parents, that there is
probably only going to be one person
in their lives, despite what the
songs say, that is willing to die
for you, and it's the very person
you probably said something horrible
to about 10 minutes ago.
So think about that.
And that was the idea of the book.
So this is the movie that it
came out of, or this is the movie
that came out from my book.
Now I had been spending
years getting movies
and projects into Hollywood.
This was the only one that
made it actually onto film.
And I thought I should
have a pretty good chance,
giving it to my favorite
film director, Bob Zemeckis,
with my favorite studio,
Walt Disney.
How could it go wrong?
So they immediately threw out
my book, told me not to come
in the doors, and they redesigned
everything and rewrote everything --
and this is an old
story in Hollywood,
but it was a new one for me.
And this is -- I wrote this for the
Hollywood Reporter, as I drew it,
to show my feelings about the
movie, or my character's feelings
about the movie, which
is abject confusion.
And it nearly brought Disney
Film Studio to its knees,
along with another movie called
Carter of Mars that year.
Mars was not a good thing for
Disney three or four years ago.
So this is the other -- this is
the second side of the triangle.
People think that because
of Donald Trump I came back,
and that would be giving him
far, far too much credit.
Trump -- Trump and I go way back.
He had a great quote
about me and said
that I was a poor man's
Doonesbury and that I was --
I'd probably quit way too late.
I started one of my
older books 20 years ago.
And I didn't think
I'd see him again.
But I think of Donald Trump
as our zombie reverse
canary in the coal mine.
You know how they used to
carry canaries into a coal mine
and when they stopped singing,
they knew they were in trouble.
We've got a canary that rose from
the dead and started singing,
and now we're really in trouble.
So this is what -- this is what --
he just represents the world
that I was about to miss.
The one that created him, and I
didn't want to miss out on it.
As far as Donald Trump is concerned,
he is basically untouchable now.
Saturday Night Live should
just quit, and give it up,
as well all the networks,
and stop, because there's --
everything we do only
generates more of the cons.
So I may talk around Donald
Trump in the future of the strip,
and I may talk about the
world from whence he comes,
or the effect it is having on
the rest of us, but he's not --
hopefully not going
to get mentioned much.
Now I saw this painting and thought,
as an illustrator --
this is a side bar.
You don't see images
of people very often
that pretty much contain everything
about the person in the painting,
and this was a very, very successful
-- he requested it painted.
He commissioned it and had it
done for his Mar-a-Lago estate.
Everything you need to
know about this man is
in that painting, and
I couldn't resist.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think this
has occurred to him.
So yes, Donald Trump
somewhat represents the --
sort of the second side
of my triangle of return.
But here's the third.
And this is a good one.
This all happened the same time.
Again, the -- a movie that
should've been a success was not,
and I was disappointed that I had so
little control over my own material.
The world was going in some new
areas that I didn't want to miss
out on as a writer, and then
-- let me tell you this story.
And I'm a story guy.
I'm a narrative guy.
That's why I got into
children's books.
I love a great story.
In comic strips, you
can tell some stories.
There is some story telling in it.
Not as much as I'd like, because it
often doesn't have a good ending.
And now, consider this one.
So there's a 10-year-old
boy in 1967, and he's --
well, this is -- let
me put it this way.
This is what set off my going
back to this side of the triangle,
was the publication
of Go Set A Watchman,
Harper Lee's unfortunate
return to the pages,
that I think she had
very little to do with,
and the hullabaloo
that happened about it.
It got me thinking about not only my
own characters, but also this story,
which I'm about to tell you.
So that's Harper, that's
her in about 1960, '61.
And in 1967, a 10-year-old boy who
fancied himself a future writer
and future artist was in his
Los Angeles English class,
and he was told to write
to his favorite author.
And he wrote a letter,
like so many people did
in those days -- this is, I'm sorry.
I'm skipping around.
This is the imagery
that lasted so long
in my imagination, I'll return to.
But this is the letter that this
10-year-old boy wrote to Harper Lee
in 1967, and it's fairly standard
as these kind of letters go.
I get them myself from
people, from kids.
But at the bottom, you see I
typed "we want more Mockingbird."
And it was my way of
saying don't stop.
Whatever you do, don't stop.
Bring my characters back.
Don't let them die.
So this letter was sent back to me,
as all of ours were in that class
from Ms. Lee, as her publisher
in those days sent all
the fan mail that she got.
It was basically returned
back to from whence it came.
She never answered mail.
So I -- the reason that picture
is there because after --
I was disappointed with my imploring
of my favorite author to return
and not let my favorite characters
die, I went on and when I was 12
or 13, I painted this, and as it
goes down in Bloom County legend,
it was my first cartoon,
and I didn't realize it.
I handed it in as an art
project to Mrs. Lewis' class,
and she gave me an F. So I showed
it to my father, who probably is
to either get credit or blame for
my sense of humor and he looked
at it, and he said one word.
I put the word back on
underneath that drawing
and handed it back
into Ms. Lewis and --
[ Laughter ]
Mrs. Lewis gave me an A,
but it was an A slash F,
meaning I had failed the
art project, but her comment
about the A was, "You're going to
be a very wealthy man one day."
She hated it, but she
recognized it, as I did,
that something magical happened.
A funny picture with a word,
either one of them
aren't particularly funny
until you put them together.
Voila. It's magic that
none of us can explain,
and I pretty much knew
my destiny at that point.
But, believe me, I'm coming
back around to Harper Lee.
Don't forget.
When it came time to invent a comic
strip in the Washington Post here
in town, didn't know
what to suggest to me.
I didn't know what
I should be doing.
I knew I should be
doing a college cartoon
that you can't sell to
a regular newspaper.
They said, "Do whatever
the hell you want.
Come up with something,
and we'll do it."
And in those days, we weren't
into marketing so much,
that you would've come up
with a brand or a gimmick
or a more catchy idea
for your strip.
I had nothing.
All I knew is I wanted to have
some funny characters in a place.
What would that place look like?
Well, it would look like Maycomb
County from To Kill a Mockingbird.
And when it came time to draw the
damn thing, I was just drawing
To Kill a Mockingbird, and when
I populated it with characters,
it was children, it was parents that
was there to comfort their kids.
When it came time to draw a
house, this was in Iowa City,
I drew the house of --
it's not Maycomb County,
but it probably looks
a little like some
of the houses in Maycomb County.
Mockingbird was informing my
art, as art should happen,
and I was continuing Mockingbird
in my own way, after my imploration
of Ms. Lee was getting nowhere.
So, I went on to do Bloom County.
Spent the next 10 years -- 20,
well, 10 years doing Bloom County.
Forty years after that little
boy's letter to Ms. Lee in 1967,
I get this piece of fan mail.
"Dear Mr. Breathed, this is
a plea from a dotty old lady
from others not dotty at all,
please don't shut down Opus.
Can't you at least
give him a reprieve?
Opus is simply the best
comic strip of all time."
And at the bottom, she
says, "Much love, Harper."
So 40 years later, the woman
who writes nobody, writes back,
finally writes back the kid that
wrote her at 10, and begged her not
to quit and not to let
her characters die.
She was not a creature of irony.
She probably could never appreciate
this on the level that I did.
But when you get a gift from
the gods like this, as a writer,
you don't easily dismiss it.
And I received these at a
time when I really wasn't
in a position to act on them.
When her book, her new book came
out, and I'd realized that she was
at the end of her life, and
her franchise was threatened
with a bad move, and her
characters -- when I say franchise,
I mean her -- the legacy
of her characters.
I thought back about
mine, and I thought back
about the letter she had written me
some years before imploring me not
to quit, combined with
those other two things,
which is my story telling I
wanted to get back control of,
Hollywood couldn't give it to
me, and great times were coming
to be a comic strip writer.
I decided to go back.
And the reason that these
are here is because I had
to rediscover what made
it fun to begin with,
because I had quit Bloom County
because it had stopped being fun
in 1989, which is what most people
stop a successful enterprise,
is because they become bored.
And when you become
bored, your guys are going
to sense it right away
and you don't want that.
So I wanted to get out
before I embarrassed myself.
Bill Watterson, I'm
sure, did the same thing.
Gary Larson did, too.
Unfortunately other strips
haven't taken the cues.
That's the approach that we --
if we're being responsible
for our readers should take.
So at one time, it was a huge
amount of fun for me to do.
So I went back and found -- and I'm
going to throw a few of these images
that I remember I flagged
just a year ago
to remind myself did
I find this fun.
Did I actually ever
laugh at my own work?
Which we're not supposed to admit,
but let me tell you, when working,
you do laugh at your own work.
And it's the only time you really
know, especially in the old days
when you didn't have Facebook,
that you might be doing it right.
So these are the images --
I always laugh at this one,
I think Barbara Bush in Bill's
arms is intrinsically funny.
What's going on, the
Vicodin is kicking in.
I remember giggling at that at
about 3 a.m. when I drew it.
Chaney's outside with a Molotov
cocktail, happy hour already.
[ Laughter ]
Anytime I can put an edited thing
over Opus' butt, I laugh at myself.
Various images --
[ Laughter ]
So I realized, and I remembered
that I used to amuse myself,
which you have to do
in this business.
So I felt much better.
[ Laughter ]
I forgot about that one.
Here's a coincidence.
My son, Milo, is best friends
with Sparky Schulz's grandson,
and it's not because we
knew each other at all.
He just happened to meet him in
Santa Barbara, and he came home
and he says, "All right,
I met a guy.
I think his grandfather
you might know."
Now, some statisticians need
to tell me what the chances are
that my son became best friends
with Sparky Schulz's grandson.
So it's pretty cool.
Again, the universe is
telling me something, right?
A year ago.
So I found my old --
I dug into my files
and found the old original
four panels from 1981,
and I started doing this, and it
was the most terrifying moment
that I've had as a creator for a
long time, because remembering how
to fill those four spaces.
And there's something unique
about a four-panel comic
strip, a three-panel strip.
It's a matter of rhythm and
timing that you can catch
and then you can lose, and
you forget how to do it.
It's not like riding a bicycle.
You do forget.
So it was terrifying.
I'd love to say that I was
totally emboldened by going back
and seeing how I could amuse myself
like an idiot, but I didn't know
that I could fill those,
which is why when it showed
up on Facebook a year ago,
you didn't see any press.
There was no stories about it.
There was no interviews,
which drove, you know,
my publicist and such crazy.
That normally this
would be a big deal.
You get as much publicity
as you can.
I wanted no publicity.
I didn't know whether I
could fill those four.
So I did the first one.
Some of you remember
this favorite one.
Anyone remember seeing this one?
[ Applause ]
The only reason I mention it is
because for an unsteady author,
or cartoonist, I got to Panel
Four, I knew exactly how to end it,
and I knew he should be pulling
up that side of his underwear,
and it was 1983 all over again.
It was as if time had
never happened.
I mean, I'm 59 now, I was 22
when I did this stuff originally.
So now it's been updated, and
you're seeing hopefully the same DNA
that was in the strip in the 80s,
but with a different twist to it.
I'd like to think so.
So I've only got a few minutes left,
and I'm going to show the
secret Watterson letters.
Now some of you -- has anyone been
to Comic Con in the last few years?
I did this there and it got
infamous and I got in a whole lot
of legal trouble about it.
And we probably have some kids
here, so I'm going to have to zoom
through a couple of
slides really fast.
If any of you wonder
what cartoonists do
when they're not doing their
strip, they write to each other.
In the old days we did, anyway.
And Bill Watterson and I
were friends via snail mail
on actual onionskin paper for dozens
and dozens and dozens of pieces
of mail, because I had successfully
got myself out of the contract
for my syndicate and
gotten my ownership back.
He was desperately trying to do it.
And he was not getting success.
He was a very, very unhappy guy.
So we had a lot of letters.
Cartoonists like to draw on
the bottom of their letters
to each other, and that's when
their inner demons come out.
So you're about to see some of the
letters that Bill Watterson wrote
to me, and with the
illustrations on the bottom,
just to see what these guys are
really like deep down inside.
Again, these are, to me, I
am the object of this stuff.
I am the target, more specifically,
and you'll see that the sweet Calvin
and Hobbes creator had a side to him
that you might not have known about.
And you have to know -- a
little bit of subtext is
that I had won a Pulitzer prize,
I had a TV special recently,
and he was dead set on
mocking me for both,
largely because I was also known
for spending a lot of the money
on fast speed boats,
which is about as opposite
of the things he could imagine
doing, since he lived on a bicycle.
So this is after the
Christmas special.
Again, this is his drawings to me,
so everything here is
drawn by Watterson.
Go ahead and quote scripture.
This is real holiday entertainment.
This is after the "A Wish For Wings
That Work" Christmas
special in 1987.
He didn't appreciate -- he didn't
think the hairball should be in it.
Now this is me in the boat.
He's drawing the syndicate guy
on the dock with the money,
and I'm stuffing the
money into my boat,
kicking my cartoon characters
off while I go spend the money
from the syndicate boss.
And he's saying, "Lazy freeloaders!
I said none of you ride until
your faces are on boxer shorts!"
Remember, he sold nothing
in his entire career.
Not a single thing with
Calvin and Hobbes on it.
And the syndicate guy is going,
"Hee hee, I'll have this guy back
in the palm of my hand in no time."
This says everything
about Bill at the time.
And there's, again, he's drawing
me as Opus in my speed boat,
and Opus -- and again, this is
the reflection on the special.
So I sound like a mixture of
Woody Woodpecker and Donald Duck.
Heck, it's worth it.
You know what was cool is he
found a picture of my boat
and he completely nailed the
stripe that was on the side of it.
That's -- so here he is.
He's got my cartoon, my
character saying to Hobbes,
"Quit the daily papers like I did.
Buy a boat.
Blow all your savings.
When you run out of gas
money, sell your home and move
to a smelly pier in Seattle."
Which is exactly what I did.
[ Laughter ]
Now -- no, no no!
This is -- it's good.
It's all good.
This is the Bill Watterson
you thought you knew.
Now I think -- I think
the dodgy one's coming up.
Oh, no. Here's the next one.
So Ronald Reagan had called
me in 1982 on the phone,
and nearly woke me up with a
compliment about that week's strip,
because it had Nancy drawn in it.
That's the short -- long -- a
very short story and a long --
short version of a long story.
So it got in the press, and I
did tell -- it was a true story.
No one believes it that when
I answered the phone to talk
to President Reagan, I
didn't know it was him.
I said, "Hello," and they said,
"Please hold for the President."
And he gets on and Michael has a
better Reagan version than I do,
so I won't try it,
but he said, "Hello.
I just wanted to tell you how much
I liked the strip this last Sunday."
And I said, "Mr. President,
I think you should know,
I'm not wearing any
pants right now."
[ Laughter ]
So he heard that story, and
this is his version of it.
[ Laughter ]
Don't you think that I could sell
these one day and put my kids
through school on this stuff?
So the last -- the
last letter that I got
from him before he went off
the grid, and he's been gone.
I never heard from him again.
The last one was this, and I
think it's okay to show you.
It's Opus drawing -- now some of
you know who the lady is on top.
It's Daisy Mae from Li'l
Abner, if you go way back.
He says, Opus is saying, "Oh,
a few more lines, la-da-da.
I'll be back on my
boat, la-da-da-da-da.
Another Pulitzer is good as mine."
So I -- I finished that
drawing and sent it back to him.
So I'm going to go through
it real quick before it ends
up on social media.
And there it is.
[ Laughter ]
I would love to let you
linger on that for a moment,
because it's really a good job.
It's really a great drawing.
So I got him back.
If some of you have read Facebook,
I got him back April Fool's Day
when I drew Calvin and Hobbes
instead of Bloom County that day,
and as I will be for
every April Fool's
for the next 10 years, by the way.
Hoping to smoke him
out, and I did not.
I don't know what he's doing, but
he's -- he refuses to surface.
So yes, I'm back having fun, and
how could I not be having fun?
Facebook, the changes are legion
between the old world
and the new with this.
I think that I'm trying this
for the first time with a foot
from the old days and
newspapers onto digital media.
I had to make a decision a year
ago whether I go back to newspapers
and make a crap load of money,
or do it for free on Facebook,
and have freedom and talk
to all of you within an hour
of drawing the strip, and
hearing what you think about it,
and your stories from your
background and your kids
and your families, and I
went with the Facebook.
Now I know it's limiting.
Some of you aren't on Facebook.
We're going to come
up with some paradigms
so there's some other options.
But I'm afraid we're not
going to newspapers again.
I don't think I could ever
be edited by the editor
of the Salt Lake City Tribune again.
So thank you so --
we're here for books,
and I know I've got to wrap up.
I am -- I have thrown the gauntlet
down as a challenge to myself.
Can I do a picture book for
children, and you all, but for kids,
starring the least predictably
appropriate character
for children's literature
I could come up with.
And I'm going to try
it with Bill the Cat.
You should know that I was
very well edited on this book.
Any good author should
also be careful
to stay true to his character.
You're often pulled off of
character for the sake of a gag
or a story line, and you're not
servicing the character's real
personality by doing it.
I found myself going
back to old instincts
as I was painting this book,
about where Bill came from,
by putting emotion and
personality into my lead character.
Bill the Cat has no emotion,
he has no personality,
he is a blank slate, he is a cipher.
And I kept, by instinct,
having his eyes, even just --
his eyeballs come together as
if he's focusing on something,
and I get a note back
from my editor, "You know,
you've got to get his focus on.
He's got to look like he's
completely nearly comatose."
And he was correct.
Bill works, I believe,
maybe you can tell me better
than I can, as a cipher.
We react to him.
We project everything
onto poor Bill.
If we love him, it's
probably because we're lonely.
It's not because Bill
is so loveable.
And how do you design that into
a picture book for children
in telling them something maybe a
little bit of a lesson at the end.
So we wrote a simple origin story
for Bill that little Binkley
at age 4 or 5 finds the animal of
his dream at an animal shelter.
It gets cruelly taken away
and sent to the North Pole
by Cat X Kitty Shoppers
International.
He loses his cat and he spends
years dreaming about him.
This caused me untold amount
of trouble from Disney
when I put Winnie the Pooh in there.
And we decided to ignore them.
But that's little Binkley
with his version
of the missing Bill the
Cat on top of his head.
I will tell you that there in the
far left of the painting there used
to be a Darth Vader doll.
They did succeed in
getting me to pull that off
with a lawsuit from Lucas Arts.
So they didn't think it
was as funny as Disney did.
So Bill gets -- Bill goes off
into a great adventure for years.
Slips into a society and a
civilization that thinks he's a god,
and they build him pyramids, and
eventually aliens come and grab him
and they lure him away
from his life of ease.
And he's delivered back to
Opus, who just recently met --
or just met him years before as
he's passing through Bloom County.
And Opus had given him his underwear
with the words Opus written in it,
which the aliens saw, read,
recognized as the source
of where this Bill -- where this cat
should go back to, brought him back
to Opus, and Opus journeys
back via every way he can
to bring Bill the Cat
back to the little boy
who loved him or needs to love him.
And he returns to Bloom County in
the end of the book, just as me
and all the rest of
you are doing, too.
So I thought it was
a nice way to end.
And I don't know if I have
any time for any questions,
but I appreciate you being here.
Do we have to exit within a few
minutes, or do I have five minutes?
You can talk.
Okay, a few minutes.
Yeah, so a couple questions
and then I'll send you back
on your way, and hope
you enjoyed it.
Oh, by the way, the -- some of the
videos you saw were Opus tests done
over the years as they tried
to bring him to the movies.
They were never going to succeed.
You can see some of the problems in
that you're trying to bring a voice
and a personality to
something that each
of you have already
done within your head.
It's a hat trick.
It's very tough.
The first one had -- anyone
know who was narrating?
Who was playing the director?
John Cleese, that's right.
A friend of mine I picked up
on the Santa Barbara beach
like a drifter and
we became friends.
The second one, does anyone
know who the voice of Opus was
in the second one when he was
pulling the kid's pants down?
Hyde Pierce, that's right.
Probably the best voice
that we tested,
and we tested hundreds of people.
Every -- we were going all
the way back to the 80s
when Steven Spielberg tried
his best, and it [inaudible].
I can tell you there won't
be a Bloom County movie,
and there won't be an Opus movie,
largely because of my experience
in Hollywood already, but as
witnessed by the last memo I got
from -- from the guys
running the studio at Miramax,
and I won't even mention
them by name,
the Weinstein brothers, actually.
[ Laughter ]
He spent years, five years we
spent trying to figure out how
to please them and get them to
sign off of on an Opus movie,
and finally the last memo I got,
and I am not making this up,
"Lose the voice from the penguin.
It's only going to
confuse the audience."
So he didn't want Opus
to talk at all.
So I knew that actually
the gods were speaking,
and this was not to be.
So it should be left
to the comic world,
which is where I've returned to.
A question, yeah, after
I dangled an opportunity.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Oh, a microphone, I
didn't know there was one.
I can't see it.
Great.
>> So I saw in your
early Facebook posts,
one of your first pictures
you put up was you working
on a computer drawing
your first cartoon.
>> Right.
>> Back as Bloom County 2015.
>> A year ago.
>> Yeah. And I was curious whether
or not you're still actually putting
any pen to paper in your process,
or if it's, at this
point, your thought --
>> Sold out to digital, totally.
I have, I still have
hundreds of sketchbooks.
Everything starts as a pencil
sketch, and then I either scan
or I move it to the computer
and I draw on the computer.
And that's just allowed me
to do it on schedule now.
And I'm being told
that we're out of time.
So --
[ Applause ]
That's the big question.
Thank you.
I think that I'm as happy as you
are that we're doing this again.
We're back together at Bloom County.
I hope you're enjoying
it as much as I am,
and you need to know I'm
really having a good time.
So thank you very much.
I'll see you next year.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.